every night in my dreams when I sing the
song
I feel a lot of
like romantic and and strong love I
always maintain that the music by itself
is less to me it's less interesting and
the film is less interesting when
they're married together is when the
magic sort of happens magic definitely
happened when the Titanic soundtrack
dropped and 25 years later our hearts
still go on for Jack and Rose the love
story I knew was going to be what the
audience was connected to I'll never let
go we wanted to take people to the level
where they would believe so much in what
these two people were sharing this
extraordinary love that you would forget
that the ship was going to sink
[Music]
that song is one of the most iconic in
movie history even winning an Oscar for
best original song we were on set with
Celine for the music video and believe
it or not it almost didn't happen it
didn't appeal to me yep Celine wasn't
feeling it when she first heard it and
it was actually her late husband Renee
who got her to make a demo and I sang
the song once and they built the
orchestra around it I never re-sang it
wow for the recording actually so the
demo is the actual recording wow but
after that I've sang it about three
gazillion times yes of course do you
understand how popular and what that
song means to this entire generation oh
it's crazy I mean so much you know such
an iconic movie like that just an iconic
song it's very special
hopefully you'll go
[Applause]
[Music]